my boyfriend and I have recently started
looking into engagement rings after a
few years of dating and living together
he told me that his mom actually already
bought the diamond that he would use for
the ring she bought him and his siblings
each diamonds when they were born to use
for their engagement apparently it's a
thing in super wealthy families which I
had never heard of I told my boyfriend
I'd rather this just be between the two
of us but he told me that he feels a
little weird not using the diamond
should I just get over it and use the
diamond even though I wanted a vintage
ring or is this a little odd I've never
heard of this before her [__] life
take the diamond of course you could
reset it into a vintage setting yeah run
with the diamond yeah of course no no
like never turn down a free Diamond it
sounds like you also you're marrying
into a wealthy family so I would just
behave you know you want more diamonds
[__] behave and take the ring [__]
and shut up yeah no like someone's
offering you a free dime and I don't see
the problem I'm seeing Solutions around
my advice is shut up take the ring
behave